هو طول مطالعه وعشاق القراءه متى ما
اضعتهم ستجدهم هنا بين الكتب المصطفى على
هذه الطاولات التي حملت بين دفيتها مئات
العناوين يقلبون اوراقها الى ان يجدوا
ضالتهم في تلك الصفحات
العراق لا يكتب فحسب بل انه لقب بالقارئ
النهم في دورته التاسعه ضمن فعاليات
المهرجان الذي انطلق من حدائق شارع ابو
نواس في العاصمه بغداد
تلك المبادره التي بدات منذ عام 2012 باتت
حدثا منتظرا يستقصب القراء والكتاب ما بين
متبرع ومشترن وموزع بالمجان المهم عدم
التوقف عن القراءه
في العراق اللي يميز هذا الموسم الموسم
التاسع انه اقيم في سبع محافظات في نفس
الوقت مع زياده لا لا اقبال وهمم تم سيتم
توزيع 70000 كتاب مجانا في عموم المحافظات
السبعه ان هذه السيده فتلقي ما تيسر لها
من نصوص كطريقه لجذب انتباه محبي هذا
النوع من المؤلفات وايضا كاسلوب للتاكيد
على ان الكتاب الورقي مازال حاضرا رغم ان
في التكنولوجيا التي اضحك للبعض ان زمن
الاوراق ولا
دليل الاقبال الان واشوف شباب صغار
وشايلين الكتب وفرحانين بيهم وبعدين
القراءه بالكتابه بالجريده والورق لها
طعمها همم الخاص وتاثيرها مهرجان حقق
نجاحا على الصعيد الثقافه الشبابيه بين
العراقين جدد عهده بمضاعفه اعداد
التوزيعات وحضور الالاف في القراءه وعلى
راي الكاتب عباس العقاد وحدها من تعطي
الانسان الواحد اكثر من حياه واحده اسراء
الصغير العربيه